hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the 1858
simultaneous blindfold exhibition that
uh morphy played against eight opponents
and this is the last game we'll be
showing
now we don't know who the gentleman he's
facing is uh is uh we only know his name
is
ca segwin and there are some instances
where it's been
uh uh well where has been shown that he
is uh 49 years of age but other than
that we don't really know all that much
we do know however that he is a very
strong player and as you'll see in this
game
he gives the morphe the most problems uh
during
this entire blindfold event so without
further ado uh let's check it out
and also it's been said of this game
that uh he's a
a gentleman of 49 who contended with
great desperation so let's see what they
mean by this
uh morphe with the white pieces opens
with e4
as he usually does we have e5 uh knight
to f3
and now d6 going for philadelphia's
defense so of course morphe will strike
in the center d4
captures captures and now knight to f6
with knight to c3 so this is all very
standard stuff
uh and bishop to e7 we have bishop to d3
morphy morphe usually develops his
bishops on d3 and e3 as you've
seen if you've been following the saga
so far we have
castles and now f4 so grabbing more
space in the center gaining very nice
control here he's gonna castle next and
continue
development and here we have c5 and it
is already as of move seven that this
position has never been reached again
so let's see how murphy deals with this
he goes back with the knight
knight to f3 and now knight to c6 uh we
have castles by morphy
and bishop to g4 and it's usually the
case when someone plays bishop to g4
plays your knight
it's either a good move or it's not a
good move uh here it's it's hard to say
but
what you what you kind of don't want to
do is give up this bishop for
knight and the morphy will put this to
the test first he develops the dark
square bishop like we said he
enjoys developing his bishops to d3 and
e3
and now a6 of course preparing b5
further expanding on the queen side so
morphy stops this with a4
and now h6 and now after all of these
so-called uh
useful moves have been depleted we have
h3 finally challenging the bishop
and now you should probably go back
something like bishop d7 bishop
the e6 even uh is possible but then then
you face moves like for example f5 and
then bishop d7 and it's uh
well it's not pleasant for black to play
this but it's not
nothing terrible yeah but instead we
have bishop captures on f3
and morphe of course is very happy to
now uh win
one of the bishops so queen captures an
f3 and
knight to b for now putting pressure on
the light square bishop but also
controlling uh
d5 uh many times so black might have
some ideas of pushing d5
we have rook 8 to d1 by morphe and now
queen to c7 developing the queen
connecting rooks and asking morphe
what what do you want to do here so here
morphy has to decide whether
he wants to go super aggressive with g4
g5 or he wants to
adjust uh you know keep everything solid
uh so for the moment he decides uh to go
b3 just a nice move uh
you know keeping everything intact and
now black should also just continue
developing you still have two
undeveloped trucks you should bring them
over
at the c8 or d8 depending on where you
wanna uh
develop your your rooks uh but here
instead we have
knight captures on d3 and the usually in
chess you don't want to capture unless
you gain something by it
also you know just saying is that to
take is a mistake
if you if you've gained nothing by
taking don't don't capture
so here c captures on d3 and now rook f2
e8 so continuing development and now
again morphe can decide whether to
immediately strike with
with some uh king side moves but for the
moment he goes d4
and here morphy wants c captures on d4
to be played because then he gets his
bishop here
probably would eliminate the knight from
f6 and then he would gain control of the
d5 square then the knight comes to d5
and that's just a monster knight right
there
black would have no pieces able of
opposing this knight because the knight
would be gone and there would only be a
dark square bishop
and b5 of course is a light square so
instead uh
after uh this d4 black does not capture
black goes queen to c6 instead now puts
more pressure on this e4 pawn if the
bishop moves the rook will also help out
here
but now comes the move that basically
shifts the game
completely in morphy's favor so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this idea while i give you a couple of
seconds it's not
probably not what you're going for but
it also might be so
let's see what you guys come up with so
uh for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding this
really anti-positional d captures on c5
also for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's not a move that you
look for because usually you never want
to capture away from the century you
either want to capture towards the
center
or not capture it all but here it just
makes sense and
morphe shows why so now you want a pawn
black can
either win the pawn back or you know
just be down upon so basically you have
to capture back
so d captures on c5 was played but now
comes
e5 and this is the point the knight is
under attack
and also the queen is under attack so
here it doesn't really matter what you
do
uh either way you're gaining the d5
square for your knight so here
queen captures an f3 was played rook
captures and now the problem is the
knight has no squares or rather no good
squares
all of these squares are taken or not
available to the knight and the only
squares where the knight can actually go
to our h5 and h7
but if the knight goes to h7 then g for
wins the knight so the knight is uh
pushed back
all the way into the corner with rook to
h7 and this is the point of the entire d
captures and c5 concept rook to d7
a nice rook lift and now white is simply
so much better
so how can you defend against this uh
the b7 pawn is hanging so rook a to b8
of course and now
knight to d5 the knight finally comes to
d5 and now it's just a monster night
uh whereas this knight on h7 is not
really well do doing all that great and
you will uh require a few more moves to
to activate it
if if if it will at all be possible so
knight to d5 with tempo as the bishop is
now hanging
so bishop back to f8 and now bishop to
f2 making room for this rook to come to
c3
uh and of course black white will want
to put more pressure to the c5 pawn in
the end to win it
and uh then morphy will just enjoy his
extra upon advantage and it's going to
be much easier for morphy's king to be
activated
than for the black king to be activated
so let's see
how segwin deals with this we have
brooke eat the d8
immediately charges that rook we have
knight to b6 now
an excellent square for the knight uh
and the rook is nicely protected so here
black trades there really isn't anything
better
captures capture is now attacking the
rook and the rook the c8 now defending
the
the c5 uh pawn as it was attacked twice
by the bishop and by the knight
but now more morphy just brings in a
third attacker to the pawn
rook to c3 and now there's no defending
the pawn here
you just have to you just have to give
it up so here rook to c7 black even
forces this
uh knight capture is not on c5 but
rather on f8
so better to trade down even further
knight captures and now
rook captures on c5 finally uh it all
came down to this from that d
captures on c5 move that happened on
move 18. now 10 moves
later morphe is up upon and uh
you know for those of you who might have
forgotten yes morphy is playing this
blindfold
from from another room so rook captures
in c5
bishop captures and now the question is
how do you
continue your only advantage is that uh
well you have two advantages basically
or three
your king is a bit more active or rather
it can be it it can be
more easily activated and number two you
have a bishop against the knight and we
have play on both sides of the board and
bishop can cover a lot more space than
than a knight can hear
and of course you are up upon let's not
forget that so or taking all this into
consideration
uh this should be a winning endgame and
and you know
unless there's some sort of a super
computer a way to hold this i don't
think it would be
it will be possible so here knight to e6
attacking the bishop making
room for the king to enter the game
morphe goes back bishop to e3
also a reasonable way to retreat because
now all of these squares are covered so
the knight really
cannot go anywhere the bishop controls
it nicely for those of you who are maybe
new to chess
and don't know about this relationship
between the bishop and knight
uh sort of a long-distance relationship
thing uh we have g6
and the g4 by morphe uh we have knights
the d8 here black
has to decide whether he wants to
continue pushing pawns where he wants to
try and activate the king somehow
but here uh black will rather try to
create some sort of a wall
so that white king cannot enter the game
so here
knight to d8 and king f2 morphy starts
bringing the king into the game
uh we have knight to c6 uh and now uh
king
e2 bringing the king deeper into the
game we have b5
captures captures and now king to d3 and
now just king to f8 and this was black's
idea kind of
uh that now the pawn covers these
squares the knight covers d square so
there's a kind of a wall that
the white king cannot breach but the
white king can always go king e4 king d5
so it's not really a problem
uh bishop to c5 check we have king to e8
and now
king to e4 like we said yeah there
there's always a way for morphy's king
to enter the position
king to d7 now king to d5 so
that's a lot more active king than the
black king on d7
knight to d8 and now comes f5 there's a
very little black can do here we have
captures captures and now
h5 we have bishop to b6 uh when you're
up upon in positions like these uh
well if you can trade off the remaining
pieces then the the king and pawn engine
will just be winning
so knight the b7 black of course will
try to prevent this but now you just
continue pushing e6 with
check captures captures with check king
e7
and now king to c6 you cannot approach
the center of the board but you can now
reach the queen side so
attacking both knight and the b5 pawn
knight d8
check and now there's really not much to
consider here the easiest way to end the
game is just to eliminate
the knight so bishop captures was played
king captures and
now not capturing the b5 pawn but that
was also
uh winning morphy just shows that
there's nothing to be done and plays
king to d6 with king to e8 and now
e7 and it was in this position on mu
that ca segwin who we know nothing about
resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh there is no way to
continue and there's no there are no
tricks in the position for example if
if if you go h4 you're just gonna play
b4 and then it's black's move there is
no stalemate so after the king moves
just king d7 x to bring the queen into
the game and just
nicely win the game so after this uh
e7 uh segwin resigned and another
excellent victory for
for paul morphy as they said of of
morphe's achievement
achievement here the blindfold players
achievement was a splendid one
for he won six games and drew two games
against a powerful opposition and
moreover made no error of real
importance and it's not just that morphe
played against eight opponents
simultaneously blindfold
but as morphe was in another room than
all of these other players i think we've
shown
uh the photo of the cafe de la regence
so how it was
well at least how it was portrayed i
don't know how exactly it looked
uh but uh it was said that morphe was
actually playing more like
against uh 50 people than against those
eight because uh
every one of those eight had more people
that was you know uh also checking out
the position helping him out and
well morphy didn't care and he completed
all of this
in one sitting without uh having any
refreshments without drinking
water or having food as he was afraid
that he would have to go
use the toilet and then people would
maybe say that he was cheating or
something
so he did all of it without uh you doing
any of it he just sat in his chair and
you know
crushed everyone well six wins two two
draws but for a blindfold simultaneous
exhibition against the opponents of
actual skill this is quite an
achievement
so not only that uh the next day he woke
up
like maybe 6 30 a.m maybe even 6 a.m and
he
came over to edge at like 7 a.m and he
told him to grab a piece of paper and
the pen that he would like
to recite all of the moves from all of
the games plus additional variations
so they have it saved you know for
historical purposes so that we can now
in 2021 analyze it on youtube so good
thing morphe was a
an early bird otherwise you know we
might not have moves to this game
uh recorded uh and yeah uh interestingly
the next day uh morphe caught a called
as they say he fell asleep near an open
window
but it was exactly on the next day
probably
harvest heard that morphe caught a cold
and he said that he would like to
continue the match now so
uh game seven is coming and we will see
how the match continues so next uh game
in the morphe saga will be
again the continuation of the match
against harvest morphe uh
with a call against harvest who is now
again i guess fully rested
so we'll see if that helps out our old
friend uh harvest or will it uh still be
insufficient
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it i really enjoyed this one and the
morphe really really played a
spectacular game
in every possible imaginable way uh i
mean
to play it like that you know in a
blindfold contest just uh
amazing stuff especially the end game uh
so
uh once again hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank rashford
stephanie
dennis cipher uh jerry draven russell
lloyd and blake terrio for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day